have you been at church yes not recently
yeah but when's the last time you went
to church I went to Sunday school when I
was a kid yeah I mean I was probably at
a church for someone's wedding or
something and did you did did you grow
up religious I did yeah not super
religious but yeah Christian did you
believe in the Lord I did yeah yeah I
believed in you still live believe in
the
Lord in my SC like oh my
God I I do speak speak to God and Jesus
all the time during my scenes in your
scenes yeah do you think he likes let's
not talk I don't talk about sex again
you know keep it wholesome this is still
wholesome yeah in the scenes okay we
could be an acting all right so um when
you're reach when you're going Jesus in
a scene right do you think he's going
yes how many spokes do you hello oh it's
Angela again she's working yeah she
always says my name when she's working
and it confuses es me because you know
there's you know me a paride and there's
other things going on the earth opens
the door oh wrong one wrong one right
right it is it is probably when I need
Jesus the most to be
honest but he probably giggles and goes
oh it's just that old silly old
Angela silly my name but when you say
his name why I mean is why do you say
his name I don't it's just habit I guess
at this oh God part of like my sex
noises God Jesus oh God Jesus Holy Ghost
I don't think anyone really says Jesus I
have I have I have you said Jesus yeah I
have not Moses oh God no that would turn
me off at this yeah oh yeah budha yeah
but then yeah that's weird you would
think she was I I feel like people who
who didn't grow up religious say oh my
God as well it's just right right but do
you believe is what I'm asking I am a
spiritual person same here but I just
yeah organized religion freaks you out
yeah a little bit yeah yeah um so you
probably didn't go to church since you
were a kid then right right as an adult
you haven't been no I haven't wow yeah
it could happen though you could get
saved you're wholesome I I don't know
how to do wholesome I'll show you how to
do wholesome if you want I'll show you
how to do no no no don't tell me how to
do wholesome you show me how to do
wholesome all right you tell me you your
version of wholesome go ahead all right
earlier before you jumped in here Bobby
was like I don't know how to do an
Australian accent okay that's wholesome
this is wholesome but I'd like actually
Angela to teach us stupid Americans some
of these uh terms uh from Australia if
you can kind of walk us through it well
I I know what these okay Bobby don't
look at the screen what's hit a frog and
toad hit a frog and toad you're driving
down the street Angela I I don't even
know what the she doesn't I'm going to
teach you right okay go ahead right and
you're driving down a a cuz you
Australian streets are different than
American streets are they not in what
way they drive on the other side that
and also there's probably things on the
side like in LA Kangaroos and stuff yeah
yeah yeah a koala well that's how I
almost got killed in Melbourne cuz you
know over here when you cross the street
how do you look no I I'm playing Candy
Crush what are you talking about Gilbert
wrong person I'm texting when you're
crossing the street which direction do
you look first I always go left left to
right left to right cuz there's a car
coming right so when I was in Melbourne
I looked left to right and nearly got
ran over oh
you
forget soad fr the frog frog and the
toad you don't you know because there's
different things right sometimes when
you're in Australia you see both a frog
and a
toad okay right and you're like what's
the difference but you can tell because
austr your eyes right and if you can hit
both of them at the same time it's good
luck for that
day God that's believable thanks man one
okay next one for the road do you
recognize any of these one for the road
is we have that for the but people
aren't like regularly saying like
they're going Walkabout or kooy like
they're not no yeah
um one for the road you got one for the
road is I'm going to have one for the
road and you drink correct kombucha
whatever you drink